ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi, today
we start a new
segment of our course.
It could be entitled 'Techniques
of Integration'.
And a subtitle could be the
difference between 'knowing
what to do and knowing
how to do it'.
You see, essentially in this
chapter, it shall be our aim
to develop various recipes
to evaluate the inverse
derivative.
So in fact, let's
call it that.
Some basic recipes.
The idea is something
like this.
Let's start with an
easier problem.
Let's suppose we start with a
differentiable function 'G'.
Suppose, for example, that 'G'
prime is equal to 'f'.
Then in terms of the language of
the indefinite integral, or
the inverse derivative, what we
have is that the indefinite
integral of 'f of x' with
respect to 'x' is then 'G of
x' plus 'c'.
Now, you see, the harder
problem is
the inverse of this.
What we're going to be talking
about is not do you find 'f'
once 'G' is given, but
techniques for finding 'G'
once 'f' is given.
And as we've seen on several
occasions already, that given
'f', it is not that easy, in
general, to find a function
whose derivative is 'f'.
In fact, in many cases, we can't
do it as explicitly as
we would like to no matter
how sharp we are.
For example, oh, I've just
reviewed this so that you can
think of this in one block.
Given 'f' to require 'G' may
not exist in familiar form.
I don't want to pin down what
familiar means any more than
that right now.
For example, the illustration
that we've used several times
already in the course, suppose
'f of x' is 'e to
the minus 'x squared''.
And we want a function whose
derivative is 'e to the minus
'x squared''.
In terms of areas, the second
fundamental theorem of
integral calculus, we can
construct such a function in a
rather straightforward way,
even though it may be
difficult to name it in terms
of familiar functions.
Namely, what we do is we take
the curve 'y' equals 'e to the
minus 't squared''
in the yt-plane.
Compute the area bounded above
by that curve, below by the
t-axis, on the left by the
y-axis, and on the right by
the line 't' equals 'x'.
And the area under the curve
is a function of 'x'.
And what we've already seen is
that in this particular case,
'A prime of x' is precisely 'e
to the minus 'x squared''.
In other words, this area
function, which is a function
of 'x', does turn out to be the
function whose derivative
with respect to 'x' is 'e to
the minus 'x squared''.
Now you see, that will not
be primarily what we're
interested in, in
this particular
phase of our course.
What we're interested in this
phase of the course is given
various classifications for
the function 'f', to find
recipes that will give us 'G' in
familiar form, where 'G' is
the function whose derivative
is 'f'.
Summarize for you
to look at here.
The objective of this block of
material is to find recipes
for finding 'G of x' for various
types of 'f of x'.
Now the best way to illustrate
what that means is to actually
pick a few examples.
And by the way, what you'll
notice in today's lecture is,
roughly speaking, we do nothing
at all that's new.
The new stuff will begin with
out next lecture essentially.
But for now what we'll really
be doing is giving us an
excuse to pull together all
of the recipes that we've
developed so far.
All of the recipes either called
indefinite integrals or
inverse derivatives.
For example, the first class
of functions which we could
handle were things of the form
integral ''u to the n' du'.
Recall that very early in our
course, we found out that the
integral of ''u to the n' du'
was ''u to the 'n + 1'' over
'n plus 1' plus a constant if
'n' was unequal to minus 1.
And then, in our last block of
material we learned to handle
the case where 'n' was
equal to minus 1.
Namely, when 'n' is minus
1, integral ''u to
the minus 1' du'.
Namely, integral 'du' over 'u'
is natural log absolute value
of 'u' plus a constant.
Now this then, is one of our
basic building blocks.
What we're saying is, if an
indefinite integral can be
written in this form, we already
have a recipe that
allows us to evaluate
the integral.
By the way, let us also point
out as was mentioned again,
several times in the past, that
'u' is the generic name
for a variable over here.
It is not important in this
recipe that we use 'u'.
What is important is that
whatever is being raised to
the n-th power inside the
integrand must be precisely
the thing that's following
the 'd' over here.
For example, instead of
'u', suppose I used
'sine x' over here.
In other words, suppose I
had 'sine x' to the n-th
power 'd sine x'.
See, what's being raised to
the n-th power is the same
thing as what's following
the 'd'.
That's all I really
care about.
In other words, if this had been
the integrand, the recipe
would have said, this is 1 over
'n + 1' times 'sine x' to
the 'n + 1' power.
Plus a constant if 'n' is
not equal to minus 1.
And it's natural log absolute
value of 'sine x' plus a
constant if 'n' is
equal to minus 1.
Again, the important thing is
not the 'u', but the fact that
what's being raised to the
n-th power is the same as
what's following the
'd' over here.
By the way, we can write this
in more familiar form.
You see, namely, notice that the
differential of 'sine x'
is 'cosine x dx'.
And consequently, in this form
what our recipe says is that
integral 'sine x' to the n-th
power times 'cosine x dx' is
given by this.
In other words, it's sine to the
'n + 1' power 'x over 'n +
1'' plus a constant if 'n'
is unequal to minus 1.
And it's the natural log
absolute value of 'sine x'
plus 'c' if 'n' is
equal to minus 1.
Again, notice this looks more
complicated than this.
But to get our problem, to get
into the form ''u to the n'
du', notice that the natural
substitution here is to let
'u' equal 'sine x'.
In which case, 'du' would
be 'cosine x dx'.
In other words, the extra factor
of 'cosine x' here
actually is to our advantage
over here.
That when we make the
substitution, it gives us the
form that we want.
With the factor missing, we're
in a little bit of trouble.
By the way, this is what makes
this a rather exciting topic.
That there seems to be no really
canned ways of finding
indefinite integrals.
That we have recipes.
Frequently, the recipe that
we have doesn't cover the
situation that we have.
In fact, I know a lot of times
in teaching a course like this
students say, why do we have
to learn these recipes and
techniques?
Why can't we just look them
up in the tables?
And the answer quite simply, is
that in many applications,
the integral that we have
doesn't appear in
that form in the table.
That frequently what we must do
is a tremendous amount of
algebraic manipulation and the
like to even get the given
integral to resemble one that
we can find in the table.
Oh, we're starting
off on a fairly
straightforward level here.
Nothing really too tricky.
But at least enough so that we
get an idea of what kind of
gimmicks are involved.
For example, suppose we had
'cosine x' to the seventh
power 'dx'.
You see the idea here is that
when you have cosine raised to
a power, it would have been nice
if a 'sine x' factor had
been in here.
Because the differential
of 'cosine x' is
minus 'sine x dx'.
And what I'm driving at here is
that we often have to have
a certain kind of ingenuity that
allows us to reduce a new
integrand to a more
familiar one.
And, as I say, there are many
techniques done in the textbook.
There'll be plenty of exercises
again, that will
allow you to experiment
on this.
All I want to do is hit a few
highlights and create the mood
as to what's going on.
For example, you see frequently
what happens is, if
we have 'cosine x' raised
to an odd power, a very
convenient way of handling this
is to split off one of
the factors of 'cosine
x' separately.
In other words, write this as
'cosine x' to the sixth power
times 'cosine x dx'.
The idea being that cosine
squared can be written as '1
minus 'sine squared''.
In other words, 'cosine x' to
the sixth power is really
'cosine squared x' cubed.
But 'cosine squared x' is '1
minus 'sine squared x''.
In other words, notice again the
role of the trigonometric
identities.
I take this integrand, write it
this way, and now you see
if I use the binomial theorem
and expand this, notice that
my typical term will have 'sine
x' to a power multiplied
by a 'cosine x'.
And that's precisely the kind
of a term that I handled in
the previous case.
And again, I'm not
going to bore you
with the details here.
That is the easiest part
of the problem.
The hard part is getting to
understand why one would want
to use this particular
kind of form.
Another variation is, what
happens if the cosine is
raised to an even power rather
than to an odd power?
How do we handle that?
Again, the same kind of use of
trigonometric identities.
For example, it would not be to
our advantage in this case,
to replace cosine squared
by 1 minus sine squared.
Because then we would wind
up with the same kind of
integrands that we started with,
only using powers of
sine instead of powers
of cosine.
You see, the idea is that if
we have a power of sine, we
want a cosine factor
to accompany it.
And inversely, if we have a
power of cosine, we'd like a
factor of sine to
accompany it.
Why?
So that we can get the integral
into the form ''u to
the n' du'.
In this particular case, a
very common device is to
invoke the identity that cosine
squared of an angle is
1 plus cosine twice
the angle over 2.
You see again, this is where
all of these particular
identities come into play.
It's not a case of saying, let's
learn these identities
so that we can recite them.
It's a case of getting into a
situation where you want a
certain answer, can't handle
it conveniently in the form
that you're in, and hope that
you can pick off a synonym
that allows you to tackle the
problem more successfully.
That's where this becomes a
matter of insight, lucky
guessing, skill, whatever
you want to call it.
It's one thing to transform an
integral into an equivalent
one, and another thing to have
that equivalent integral be
something that you can handle.
Well, at any rate, for example
in a problem of this type, a
tendency is to write cosine
sixth theta as
cosine squared cubed.
Cosine squared theta is 1 plus
cosine 2 theta over 2.
To cube this we can take
out the factor of 1/8.
You see, we use the binomial
theorem to expand 1 plus
cosine 2 theta cubed.
And notice that of the
terms that we get,
this term we can handle.
This term we can handle,
it's just cosine
to the first power.
Which involves a sine term
when we integrate.
And here's a cosine cubed.
But we've just seen how you can
handle something to an odd
power, so that reduces
this term to a
type that we can handle.
And then we see what?
That we have another term
in here, which is
cosine squared 2 theta.
That's an even power
of cosine.
Again, we do what?
We write cosine squared 2 theta
as 1 plus cosine of
twice this angle.
That's 1 plus cosine
4 theta over 2.
In other words, we keep reducing
these things, always
hoping to break them down into
collections of problems that
we solved before.
As I said, these are things
that we'll drill on in the
exercises and I think it will
become more meaningful there.
Here, as I say, the main aim
is to create the mood that
what we're trying to do is to
reduce unfamiliar problems to
equivalent familiar
ones to which we
already know the answer.
Now again, in the way of review,
sometimes an integrand
occurs in the form of the sum or
difference of two squares.
We've already handled this in
terms of the inverse circular
functions and the inverse
hyperbolic functions.
It's covered for the first time
in our textbook at this
particular stage
of the course.
And I think it's a tough enough
concept so that it's
worth emphasizing
at this stage.
So I just separate this
particular type out.
How do we handle sums and
differences of squares?
And what I intend to show is,
is that by a suitable
trigonometric function, either
circular trigonometric or
hyperbolic trigonometric, we can
always reduce that kind of
a problem to the type
that we can handle.
Again, to keep computation at a
minimum, I have not tried to
pick a rather complicated
situation.
In fact, I've picked ones where
you can very easily look
them up in the table
if that was the
main aim of the exercise.
You see here, it's not so much
that I want to get this
answer, as much as it is that
I want to emphasize the
technique that one uses.
The idea is something
like this.
Here we see the difference
of two squares.
That's the square root of a
squared minus x squared.
What this should do for us is
to suggest a right triangle
whose hypotenuse is a and one
of whose sides is 'x'.
That's the diagram I've
drawn over here.
This is my reference triangle.
As I say, we've done this
before, but I would like to
reinforce this at this
particular stage.
Especially now that we're more
familiar with both the inverse
circular and inverse hyperbolic
functions.
At any rate, we use this
reference triangle.
From this triangle, the easiest
relationship to pick
off involving 'x' is that sine
theta is 'x over a', or 'a
'sine theta'' equals 'x'.
From which it follows that
''a' cosine theta
'd theta'' is 'dx'.
The square root of ''a squared'
minus 'x squared''
over 'a' is cosine theta.
Therefore, the square root
of ''a squared' minus 'x
squared'' is 'a cosine theta'.
If we now make this substitution
in this
particular integral, we wind up
with integral 'dx' over the
square root of ''a squared'
minus 'x squared'' is equal to
integral 'd theta'.
Which is theta plus 'c'.
And since theta is the number
whose sine is 'x over a', we
have that the answer to this
problem is inverse 'sine 'x
over a'' plus a constant.
Again, just a straightforward
review, but a
rather important technique.
In our textbook, this is put in
a separate section, and the
technique is called
trigonometric substitution.
And I just wanted to show
you what motivates the
trigonometric substitution.
The harder part as I mentioned
in our previous lecture, is
how you motivate trigonometric
substitutions when it's the
hyperbolic functions
that are involved.
You see, what I'd like to do now
is instead of dealing with
the square root of ''a squared'
minus 'x squared'',
let me just reverse the
order of the terms.
And now let me take integral
'dx' over the 'square root of
''x squared' minus
'a squared'''.
Notice that the difference
between ''x squared' minus 'a
squared'' and ''a squared' minus
'x squared'' is just a
factor of minus 1.
And the fact that that minus 1
is under the square root sign,
really means in a certain manner
of speaking that you've
multiplied by i, the square root
of minus 1, to transform
the integral that we
just had into this
particular form here.
And in terms of our lecture on
the hyperbolic functions that
should, in some way, give us a
preview of things to come in
the sense that the hyperbolic
functions are very strongly
related to the circular
functions.
My technique for doing this--
and again, this is highly
subjective.
It's very simple.
I learnt the circular functions
long before I learnt
the hyperbolic functions.
Consequently, I feel very
much at home with
the circular functions.
As a result, whenever I see the
sum or difference of two
squares, I always think in
terms of a triangle.
I make a circular trigonometric
substitution.
If that works for me, fine.
I haven't lost anything.
If it doesn't work for me, it
gives me the hint that I can't
seem to get in my own mind
without this hint as to which
hyperbolic function
I should use.
Let me show you this in terms
of this particular example.
If I saw this problem from
scratch and didn't have any
previous knowledge of how to
handle this I'd say, this
seems like I should think of
a right triangle whose
hypotenuse is 'x' and one
of whose sides is 'a'.
So I think of this particular
reference triangle.
Now, thinking of this triangle,
and in fact, even
look at this triangle, I very
easily pick off that 'x' is
equal to 'a cosecant theta'.
See, 'x over a' is 1
over sine theta.
That's cosecant theta.
Therefore and remembering how to
differentiate the cosecant,
I take the differential of both
sides and I find that
minus 'a cosecant theta
cotangent theta
'd theta'' is 'dx'.
Again, from this diagram I see
that the square root of ''x
squared' minus 'a
squared'' is--
well, let's see.
The square root of ''x squared'
minus 'a squared''
over 'a' would be
cotangent theta.
So the square root of ''x
squared' minus 'a squared''
itself is 'a cotangent theta'.
Making the substitution in the
integral 'dx' over the square
root of ''x squared' minus 'a
squared'', notice that the
'a's cancel, the cotangent's
cancel, and I'm left with
'cosecant theta 'd theta''
and a minus
sign inside my integral.
In other words, somehow or
other, this circular
trigonometric function replaces
the integral 'dx'
over the 'square root of ''x
squared' minus 'a squared'''
by integral minus 'cosecant
theta 'd theta''.
And the point I'd like to
emphasize at this particular
stage is that we don't
say that the
substitution has failed.
The substitution
has been made.
We have replaced an integral
involving 'x' by
one involving theta.
It's just that in the same way
that it's difficult to
integrate secant theta--
in fact, that will be later
in this block of
material we'll do that.
But the point is that secant
and cosecant are rather
difficult functions
to integrate.
In fact, at this stage of our
development, we do not know a
function whose derivative
is cosecant theta.
Consequently, we don't know one
whose derivative is minus
cosecant theta.
We seemed to have arrived
at an impasse here.
We have successfully made the
substitution, but the key
point is that the new integral
is no easier for us to handle
than the old integral.
Now, here's how I visualize the
hyperbolic substitutions.
We did this in the
last lecture.
I think it's tough enough, so
I'd like to do it a second
time and give you a chance of
seeing how easy this is once
you see the structural form.
Notice that the substitution I
made here was 'x' equals 'a
cosecant theta'.
The cosecant was the
key step here.
The reference triangle, knowing
how to draw this
geometrically, allowed me not
to consciously have to think
of the trigonometric
identities.
But what I really did in
evaluating this problem, if I
left the diagram out and wanted
to do it analytically,
the identity that I made use
of was the one that said
cosecant squared theta minus
cotangent squared theta is
identically 1.
In other words, I would like an
identity for the hyperbolic
functions that has the structure
that the difference
of two squares is
identically 1.
The easiest one I can think of
is the one that says cosh
squared theta minus sinh
squared theta is 1.
You see, structurally, these
two are equivalent.
In other words, sinh and cosh
are related hyperbolically,
the same way that cotangent and
cosecant are in terms of
circular functions.
The identification is this.
Since in the original problem I
tried 'x' equals 'a cosecant
theta', and since the
identification here is that
cosecant and cosh are matched
up, what I try next-- see once
this has failed, I very quickly
now say, OK, what I'll
do is instead of 'x' equals 'a
cosecant theta', I'll try 'x'
equals 'a cosh theta'.
That's exactly what
I did over here.
'a cosh theta' equals 'x'.
From which it follows
that 'dx' is 'a
sinh theta 'd theta''.
The square root of ''x squared'
minus 'a squared'' is
just ''a squared' cosh
squared theta'.
That's 'x squared'.
Minus 'a squared'.
That can be written as the
square root of 'a squared'
times the quantity 'cosh
squared theta minus 1'.
Now, the interesting point is
the 'cosh squared theta minus
1' turns out to be sinh
squared theta.
In fact, if we want to just look
back here for a moment,
recall that's exactly what
we have over here.
That cosh squared theta is 1.
Well, cosh squared theta is
1 plus sinh squared theta.
cosh squared theta minus 1
is sinh squared theta.
And you might, say wasn't
that terrific?
What a lucky break it was that
this complicated expression
just happened to be sinh
squared theta.
And now taking the square
root I get a sinh theta.
The thing I'd like to point
out is that the element of
luck was removed from this at
the instant that I recognized
the fact that cosh and sinh
were related by the same
identity that cosecant
and cotangent were.
In other words, I rigged this
thing so that when I finally
had to take this particular
difference, I had to wind up
with an easy square
root to extract.
You see, I had the right
structure to begin with.
At any rate, to make a long
story short here, 'dx' is 'a
sinh theta 'd theta''.
The square root of ''x squared'
minus 'a squared'' is
'a sinh theta'.
Therefore, 'dx' over the square
root of ''x squared'
minus 'a squared''.
Well, look how nicely
this works out.
The a sinh theta cancels from
both the numerator and the
denominator.
And it turns out that the
integral that I'm looking for,
'dx' over the square root
of ''x squared' minus 'a
squared'' is just theta
plus a constant.
But now, recalling that a
cosh theta equals 'x'.
In other words, cosh theta
is 'x over a'.
And therefore, theta is 'inverse
cosh 'x over a'', I
arrive at the result that this
integral is 'inverse cosh 'x
over a'' plus a constant.
In other words, what I hope that
these two little examples
show is that when I have the
sum or difference of two
squares, the trigonometric
substitutions will usually
give me a crack at getting an
equivalent integral that will
be easier to handle.
What may happen is that the
circular functions won't help
me, but the hyperbolic
ones will.
Or vice versa, and I hope that
you see how these are so
delicately connected.
Well, there is one final type of
technique that I would like
to show for today's lesson
that's related to what we've
already done.
And with that, we'll conclude
today's lesson and go into
some more elaborate
recipes next time.
But this is a take-off on our
old high school construction
of completing a square.
In other words, let's suppose
we have an expression of the
form 'ax squared' plus
'bx' plus 'c'.
And this may sound
old hat to you.
You may remember this as looking
pretty much like the
development of the quadratic
equation.
The idea works something
like this.
First of all, I can factor
an a out of here.
I'm assuming that a is not 0.
In fact, if a were 0, I
really wouldn't have a
square term in here.
I factor out an 'a' and I'm
left with 'a' times 'x
squared' plus ''b over
a'x' plus 'c over a'.
Now it turns out that whenever
you have something of the form
'x squared' plus something times
'x', to convert that
into a perfect square.
And again, we'll have ample
opportunity to practice this
in the exercises.
You take half the coefficient
of 'x' and square it.
Half the coefficient of 'x'
here is 'b over 2a'.
If I square that it's 'b
squared' over ''4a' squared'.
Now to keep the identity intact
here, if I add in 'b
squared' over ''4a' squared',
I must subtract that.
In other words, I just add and
subtract this term that will
make this a perfect square.
In fact, what is 'x squared'
plus ''b over a'x' plus ''b
squared' over '4a' squared''?
You'll notice that
this is just ''x'
plus 'b over 2a' squared'.
'x squared'.
Just multiply this thing out.
You see how this particular
thing works.
In other words, what I've done
is I can write this as 'a'
times a perfect square.
And by the way, what's left over
here if I multiply these
two terms through by 'a'?
This is 'c' minus 'b
squared over 4a'.
In other words, recognizing that
this is ''x' plus 'b over
2a' squared'.
And multiplying these two terms
through by 'a', I wind
up with the fact that ''ax'
squared' plus 'bx' plus 'c'
can always be written in
this particular form.
This is called completing
the square.
And notice that this is now a
perfect square and this is
some constant.
And the question that comes up
is, what does this have to do
with integral calculus?
In other words, with finding
antiderivatives.
And again, as is so often
the case, and granted
that as this course--
especially this chapter gets
more complicated, the degree
of sophistication will
become much greater.
But the basic idea will always
remain the same.
Somehow or other, we will always
try to reduce a new
situation to a more
familiar one.
In other words, let's suppose
now we don't have an integrand
that's the sum and difference of
two squares, but we have an
integrand that involves a
quadratic expression.
Say, for example, we have
'dx' over ''ax' squared'
plus 'bx' plus 'c'.
Well, you see, using hindsight
rather than foresight, I
already took care of this
problem before we started.
Namely, we just finished
completing
the square over here.
Namely, what is ''ax' squared'
plus 'bx' plus 'c'?
Notice it can be written
in what form?
Let's come back here
and take a look.
It's 'a' times ''x'
plus 'b over 2a'
squared' plus some constant.
I don't care what it
happens to be here.
I'll just call that constant
'c sub 1'.
And by the way, notice depending
upon the relative
sizes of 'a', 'b', and 'c', this
constant can be either
positive or negative.
Or in fact, even 0.
So to handle that what I'll say
is I can always write this
denominator in the form 'a'
times ''x' plus 'b over 2a'
squared' plus or minus
some constant.
Where I'm assuming now that
the constant is positive.
That's why I put the plus
or minus sign in.
It's plus some positive constant
or else it's minus
some positive constant.
Now what I can do is factor out
an a from the denominator.
If I factor out an a from the
denominator here, I have 1
over 'a' times a certain
integral.
What integral?
'dx' over 'x plus 'b over 2a'
squared' plus or minus still
some constant.
In other words, I
had 'c1' here.
I factored out on 'a'. 'c2'
was actually 'c1 over a'.
I just factored out an 'a'
from this thing here.
But it doesn't make
any difference.
The important point is I now
have this written in this
particular form.
Now if I assume that 'c2' is a
positive constant, notice that
any positive number is
a perfect square.
Namely, it's the square
of its square root.
And again, as I say with the
exercises, this will become
clearer when we work with
specific numbers.
But the idea here is what?
This is some perfect square,
which I'll call 'k'.
And in other words, this
integrand can now be written
in the form '1 over a', 'dx'
over 'x plus 'b over 2a'
squared' plus or minus
'k squared'.
Well, again, what am
I leading up to?
If I now make the substitution
that 'u' equals 'x plus 'b
over 2a'', notice that my
denominator simply becomes 'u
squared' plus or minus
'k squared'.
In other words, my denominator
now has the form of either the
sum or difference
of two squares.
On the other hand, if 'u'
is 'x plus 'b over
2a'', what is 'du'?
Remember, 'b' and 'a'
are constants.
'b over 2a' is a constant.
The derivative of
a constant is 0.
So 'du' is equal to 'dx'.
In other words, notice that if
I now make this substitution
in here, outside I have a '1
over a', inside I have 'du'
over ''u squared' plus or
minus 'k squared''.
In other words, when I have a
quadratic I can write that in
the form the sum and/or
difference of two squares,
simply by completing
the square.
Simply by completing square.
In other words, I can solve the
problem of the quadratic
by converting it back into an
integral, the type of which
I've solved before.
And this, by and large, becomes
the technique that we
will use throughout
this chapter.
Well, at any rate, I won't
go into that in any more
detail right now.
We will pick up additional
techniques in our next lecture.
And until the next
lecture, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.